cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump into the news
ladies and gentlemen Bob Menendez has
been charged with accepting gold bar
bribes hey man I gotta say if you're
gonna take bribes gold bars is the way
to do it smart so uh New Jersey Senator
Bob Menendez has been indicted for
bribery according to a statement from
the United States Attorney for the
southern district of New York Menendez
is currently the chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee the Democrat
and his wife Nadine have been under
federal investigation since 2022. the
couple's allegedly believed to have
taken 400 000 with gold bars from New
Jersey developer and former bank
chairman Fred dayabis how do you
pronounce it diabs
and his associates while Hana and Jose
Uribe in exchange Menendez reportedly
agreed to use his official influence to
sway the justice department which had
accused diabus I don't know how to
pronounce that
um
of Bank crimes newly unsealed documents
filed in New York accused Menendez and
his wife of accepting hundreds of
thousands of thousand bribes in exchange
raising menendez's power and influence
as a senator to seek protect and enrich
Hannah how do you pronounce that your
Arabi Arabia yes
that there's a little um typo there it
says d-a-i instead of di to the benefit
of the Arab Republic of Egypt wow well
the first thing I'm going to say is the
federal government especially the
southern district of New York gets zero
benefit of the debt from me and I gotta
say I I
am biased against you know individuals
like Menendez and many Democrats but I
will tell you this I am more biased
against the southern district of New
York for the things they've done are
they the ones that have been going after
they're after project Veritas maybe I'm
wrong about that but I know that they're
they're going after Trump not a fan of
these guys and so I will actually say
you know I'll give Menendez the benefit
of the doubt let's let's hear what hear
what they'd say first and foremost no
matter who someone is innocent until
proven guilty but uh I am not going to
jump on throwing Menendez under the bus
simply because he's a Democrat I do not
trust sdny I do not trust Federal
prosecutors I think the moment the feds
tried the ends and New York goes after
Trump for political reasons anything
they do is Tainted no matter what so
maybe they want to go after Menendez
fine maybe it benefits Republicans in
the long run sure whatever don't care
these people are evil and I don't trust
them do you guys have a gold sponsor
because if you do this would be a great
time you know hey the politicians are
trying to on the podcast take the gold
okay so what what do you think you
should be doing no but uh yeah I mean
it's interesting there probably has to
be a reason they're going after him I'd
have to imagine I mean you've seen the
same thing you said southern district of
New York right you kind of saw how the
political system in New York went after
Andrew Cuomo one of their own because
you know clearly something there fell
out of favor so I really wonder what the
the backstory is here because I couldn't
imagine they're just gonna go after him
just because oh he's a corrupt
politician right so there's probably
something more to the story I would have
to imagine all Menendez has to do right
now is put out a press conf have a press
conference and say that one week ago he
began drafting a resolution for the
Senate to end the persecution and
prosecution of Donald Trump because it
was disruptive to our democracy and then
all of a sudden he's being indicted and
just let her rip yeah interesting I mean
because look
the Democrats are in the seat of power
yeah what could he say right now in
favor of Democrats that would get
Democrat nothing if he came out and said
I hate Donald Trump please they'd be
like too bad we don't care yeah but if
he came out and was like I wanted to I I
was arguing to end the prosecution of
trump because this is not the way the
Democratic party should be operating
that would actually earn him some
benefit people he would get political
tribalist being like well let's just
slide on this one keep talking
I I don't really have a take uh other
than you know if you can get gold bars
get them I'm very glad you started off
the segment talking about the
presumption of innocence that's a real
important part of the next 20 or 30
years of American livelihood yeah but
the problem is we we be good people so I
will I have no problem saying like I
don't know what this guy was involved in
but you better prove it before I'm
willing to throw someone in jail or
whatever every day beyond but the
problem is the Democrats don't extend
that in their Direction no so so at this
point is it like well you know what you
stick that label on your name and you
get you get no favors from me no that
that's what they I think that's what
deep the Deep power wants is for us to
forego rule of law and just start going
at each other they're frothing waiting
for you but they're using the law like
to go if you're not I don't I don't see
how you get to foregoing the rule of law
like if you are pro if he's being
prosecuted by New York they're you know
they're using the law against him now
granted I mean it looks like it doesn't
look good it looks it looks like he
actually did this stuff but that being
said you should be innocent until proven
guilty you know or you should be treated
that way but it's not like it's not like
they're after like it's not like there's
there's an attempt to get around the law
or circumvent the law except for on his
his case I don't see that that it's a
right left thing is what I guess is what
I'm getting here's the thing is that I
don't even want to use the term
Democrats I think it's more so there's a
lot of people in the uni party who have
gotten away with genuine legitimate
crimes that you know no one ever
indicted no one ever tried to even
investigate so I do think to some degree
considering what they're doing to Trump
and you know a lot of people on our side
for very frivolous reasons very often I
do think in the future if we ever want
to kind of balance out the playing field
I do think you're gonna have to at some
point try to hold the other side or the
unit party I should say really more so
accountable for the things that they're
just straight up getting away with that
are real crime so I'm not saying
obviously fabricate crimes or try to you
know just go after people to go after
them but I think you've seen them turn a
blind eye to a lot of uh establishment
politicians over the years and I think
to balance out the situation now I think
you know
look and it's not just it's probably not
going to happen but it's just you know
in in theory they ignore Epstein right
all of them do not and and the problem I
have is that for a lot of these powerful
corrupt individuals that we know about
any prosecutor could have got after him
absolutely yeah yeah right there there
is justification for when it comes to
these politicians and high profile
individuals they do work in the
jurisdictions and jurisdictions all
across the country yeah there there's
there are grounds for it that's why New
York is going after Trump they'll find a
way but Republicans don't do I was
thinking last night like if you um tear
open an evil system and you rip back the
curtain and show everyone how evil it is
you're you're you're providing a threat
for the system stability even if it's
evil if you expose it it can disrupt and
then the system could fall apart so what
will happen is people will try and just
show you a little bit of it at a time
but that's like poking a needle into a
balloon and trying to to stop it from
popping trying to hold it tight and it's
like once evil gets exposed a little the
rest of it just comes pouring out and
like trying to suppress people's
awareness of it is almost doing more
damage to the system than just letting
it you know building up yeah that's what
it feels like there is there is a
posture full of pus on the United States
that they just keep slapping Band-Aids
over and it just keeps getting bigger
and worse yeah and when this thing pops
oh it's gonna suck but man you can't
just keep thinking like this is what
they do in terms of the economy as we
were talking about with debt and War and
one of the theories uh there there is a
theory I could call it conspiracy I
don't know if it's a conspiracy theory
hypothesis that the purpose of the
stimulus during covid was not really
coveted it was hey here's our chance to
flood the flood the economy with with
printed money so that we can pay down
the debt and kick the can down the road
for a couple more years because a
monetary system which produces more debt
than currency eventually collapses
I mean well that's something that that
austrians and Libertarians and even
fiscal conservatives have been talking
about I mean we are in a new paradigm
now considering the fact that the the
government and the Federal Reserve is
working under a modern monetary you know
Theory like so it's mmt all the way the
idea that they're taxing to pay for
things that's something that people
should
and just put out of their heads the
point of taxes is to control inflation
that's it just to take money from people
they're gonna you they're going to print
up the money that they that they you
know whatever they need to do whatever
that whatever uh program they want
whatever they need they just print it
the fact that the the federal government
collects taxes means that the dollar has
a value because you have to get dollars
to pay those taxes they use taxes and
interest rates control to control
inflation there is nothing backing it
the only value that comes from your
dollar is is from the demand for taxes
so the we have to get away or people
should try to get away from the idea
that we are using taxes to pay for
projects and the the argument against
mmt is it gives the government
unlimited authority to print money and
do whatever they want with finances
outside of of the let me let me let me
let me read some of this real quick from
NBC just to give some context apparently
his wife is also being charged and they
say that federal agents said they
discovered many of the items many of
these items were when they executed
search warrants in the couple's home
they found more than 480 000 in cash
much of it stuffed into envelopes and
hidden in clothing closets and a safe
including jackets to bring the Senator's
name that were hanging his closet as
well as more than seventy thousand
dollars in Nadine's safe deposit box the
indictment alleges I mean this is pretty
this is pretty much uh whose money was
he holding they got photos yeah of like
a sweater let me let me pull this up
because I was just reading it on my
phone let me pull it up is there I
wanted to ask you Phil do you know if
any historical examples of a Nation or
an empire being in the level of debt
that we are no right now so this is kind
of like Uncharted Territory no and also
mmt is still a fairly new Theory yeah so
you did you guys yeah yeah I wanted to
comment really quickly on uh Tim's
quote-unquote conspiracy theory it's
funny we talk about the great reset
living in pods and very often the
natural reaction is people would never
accept that but that is the thing is
that when everything becomes
unaffordable when you can't afford a
home what are you going to live you
can't afford food you know what's what's
the next reaction to that so if it all
lined up and that was the purpose of
covid to basically destroy the current
Order In traditional American way of
life in so that way it gets worse and
worse and now eventually people 10 years
from now will basically just accept a
quasi-grate reset I think it's uh
interesting to say the least right I I
wanna I we got this picture pulled up
and it is
it's a decent amount of money I mean
it's probably a couple Grand serious
question though for like for what reason
honest question I'm not saying I'm not
it's not rhetorical honest question for
what purpose
would someone have five to ten thousand
dollars and hundred dollar bills and
envelopes hidden in just like stuffed in
the pocket in a closet in a sweater it's
not his that's what I that's my initial
thought is whose money is this and why
is he holding on to it I think he's a
scapegoat I think they've thrown him
under the rug saying look the doj plays
fair look at us I mean it could be his
money because if he is taking bribes
does it make sense he doesn't want a
paper trail absolutely he does hard
paper but we live in a world of crypto
like I think it's very crypto's not safe
yeah they got AI that can track all that
this guy's been hard this guy was
notoriously uh pushing hard against one
of the crypto uh companies uh was he
like a year ago I read that earlier
today and I didn't didn't dig into uh
how bad it was but it's like it's like
uh you know harmonious that this guy
who's anti-crypto is taking bribes so
like what you know who's the real
villain in this situation yo look at
these gold bars wow
gold bars what do you do with gold bars
put him in a safe it says Swiss band
Corporation I know but like
look man I know gold is valuable but
how are you going to move this amount of
money like what's your plan if you're a
regular person and you're like I would
like to hedge you know have a hedge or
or you know a hard asset or whatever
it's like oh I totally get it totally
get buying gold I have a little bit I
have most more silver than gold but no
makes sense but if you're taking bribes
what are you gonna do with it there was
a bunch in lots of envelopes different
envelopes that makes me think that
they're gonna traffic them they're going
to start trafficking cash off site they
may have already started trafficking
cash off site if they're in little
envelopes well I mean you know what's
kind of funny about this though is this
is a very old school New York New Jersey
political Scandal he has a bunch of Cash
Money gold bars Mafia very aesthetic
going there uh you know it kind of
amuses me to tell you the truth it's an
old school political history like
Breaking Bad Ozarks right you know right
yeah that's funny oh yeah so this is uh
Menendez was going hard on Venezuela's
uh talk of
involving utilizing crypto okay now I I
I got I just gotta say right here nah
this doesn't move move the needle for me
I mean he's got a couple Grand in 50s
he's got 20s right there and it looks
like it might be like
so say 1400 1400 Maybe
in 20s
if they're super rich
having like a thousand bucks in a pocket
somewhere a couple like I'm okay I I can
understand that for whatever but that
stack of hundreds I'm like
for what for what purpose well it's now
the in the envelopes because if a drug
dealer has like a big block of weed
that's one thing but if they have a
bunch of little baggies of it all split
up that's intent to sell that's intent
to move basically
is I mean how rich is this guy what's
his net worth I don't know I'm not
really I don't really buy that he was
attempting to move the money I think he
was just sitting on it honestly I I have
a feeling you know if you're if you've
got gold bars like what what is it what
is move mean to you give it to his
friends send it overseas I'm not sure
put it in a pocket every time every week
all right all right hold on we got
opensecrets.org saying that his net
worth as of 2018 was five hundred and
forty one thousand dollars
Ain't No Way Ain't No Way someone who's
net whose net worth is just a half a
mill is drop in 510k in the coat pocket
and ignoring it if this dude was worth a
couple mil I'd be like maybe it was out
partying with the boys at a bar he took
out a bunch of cash maybe he was doing
Vegas or whatever I don't know there's
there's you I mean you know there's
reasons but not a dude who's worth this
and his assets are apparently his house
so he's worth half a million dollars but
375 is his house
and then he makes 170 75 000 a year that
is weird for him to be worth so little
money honestly from from I don't think I
can't believe this right where like he's
a New York but they got to file their
disclosures though yeah okay hold on
here uh I don't know what CA Club India
it says his net worth is 18 million oh
my gosh okay but I don't know which ones
which one's real I know that he's got to
uh uh you've got well the open Secrets
was 2018 right so right it was a while
ago yeah I mean wow being uh being in
government makes you a lot of money
apparently you know according to what is
wealthypersons.com Menendez Googled how
much is one kilo of gold worth around
the time his wife accepted alleged
bribes
wow I Google that uh probably once a
week to check on the price and you guys
know that um
MSNBC host and it's all his wife imagine
your wife his daughter his daughter as a
host on MSNBC I'm pretty sure really
yeah
daughter who do you guys know who gave
the bribe alleged bribe does it say in
the article it doesn't I don't think so
Bob Menendez is Alicia
let's see uh yeah uh Alicia Alicia
Menendez uh anchor for MSNBC is she
still I think
uh she's how she has hosted uh well I'm
pretty sure she does stuff for them but
you know is it is any surprise to to to
like it's it's one big happy family tree
everybody you know this is what they do
yeah
granted I'll say it again like innocent
until proven guilty you know what I mean
I I don't care for this
Googling how much is a kilo of gold
worth doesn't prove that he took a bribe
right like for all we know his wife
bought gold and they were like we're
gonna get rid of this guy because he's
not playing ball with us yeah I don't I
don't trust Bob Menendez I mean he's
been accused of a lot of things before
and so I'm not giving I mean first of
all for the most part Democrats ain't
getting the benefit of the doubt from me
right you know well that's the thing is
the system is so corrupt these days that
it shouldn't be like this but the minute
I see them go after someone yeah exactly
the minute I see them go after someone
my first instinct isn't okay what do
they do in the terms of the crime it's
why are they going after him right and I
think that's kind of a natural reaction
we have in a lot of American life these
days you know thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time